so you guys may not know this but there
was an extended trailer of a soccer
style celebration which featured extra
footage now this is leaked and I will be
showing you guys a scene from this
trailer in a second but we'll have to be
a bit more careful because Disney have
been blocking and taking down videos
mine included by showing footage from
this trailer but I thought I'd take one
for the team and I'll show you guys this
footage as there's a really cool detail
in the scene so Sabine is seen using the
speed of bike here as she is most
definitely going over the speed limit
she decides to play limber of the ship
as she does a cool little drift
underneath this ship and apparently this
ship that she goes underneath is a Big E
stroke so what I'll get you guys to do
is to look up a little bit and look at
this ship here so apparently this is an
e-wing which is basically a replacement
for the X-Wing by the new Republic
basically just a new ship model which
they started to roll out and start to
use now I believe this was originally a
legend ship so I gotta say I'm really
happy to see them draw more elements
from Legends and then to bring it into
our Star Wars and to make it Canada
because it seems like Dave filoni is
definitely drawn on more Legends aspect
especially in this trailer with a hint
of heir to the Empire I'm really hoping
to get a live action adaptation for that
for his live action film and I'm not
gonna lie it is looking like we might
get that it seems like they're taken
front in that direction which I cannot
be more happy about but anyway I thought
the speeder scene was very very cool and
there are also other scenes from this
trailer which I bet most of you guys
haven't seen so if you do want to see
more scenes from this league trailer let
me know in the comment section below and
I'll consider making a video on it
thanks for watching guys